hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game that was played in 1985
it was a very strong tournament in
hoovering and here we have Alexander
believsky facing John Nunn and uh the
tournament Was Won by uh not the two of
them the two of them actually shared
second place the tournament Was Won by
uh I don't want to trick you guys so let
me just check real quickly uh the
tournament Was Won by Yeah by Yan Tim
and he had nine out of 13 and uh
balowsky and unshared second place with
eight out of 13. uh but this is the game
that everyone talks about not only in
that tournament but everyone talks about
it even today as this is uh this game is
known as to be Jon Nan's Immortal game
and you guys have uh requested it over
the years that I should show it but I
always was saving it and today is um uh
John's 68th birthday uh so I decided to
show it now and the the video that I
made the nuns game against Anand that he
completely obliterated on and in the
martial attack uh I um I mentioned that
okay maybe John was not a world champion
but he was one of the absolute strongest
players of uh of uh adira that he
competed in uh here uh during this game
he was number nine in the world I can
even pull up um a list here so let me
just check it out there you have it so
this is the list of January 1985 so okay
we have Kasparov and karpov of course
number one and number two then demon
magana and belowski was number five
portishein polgesky and John number nine
in the world so uh two incredibly strong
players and um the game is absolutely
fascinating and uh of course that's why
you guys requested it so so much but
what I wanted to say is that uh I
mentioned that he never really achieved
that the title of world champion which
is not uh correct because he is a three
times world champion at problem solving
and also last year uh in Italy he won
the world senior championship for a plus
65 years of age I think he was a 67 uh
when it was played and he uh dominated
the field making him uh a uh basically a
four-time world champion and not in
classical chess but a world champion
nonetheless and he uh is a very
successful uh author he published like
30 books uh I don't think all 30 were
his work some were co-authored uh but
still I mean 30 books with your name on
it uh it's absolutely incredible work
and they are some of the best best books
that you can possibly get if you want to
improve at chess
and uh yeah I mean I have uh uh aside
from chess said this was played in 1985
in 1981 uh he was a lecturer at the
Oxford University he was the uh as they
say he was the youngest player uh to uh
enroll in the in the Oxford University
since like 16th century he he enrolled
at 15 years of age and then in 1981 he
decided okay I'm not gonna be a
professor anymore I'm gonna do just
seriously and then he became a
professional chess player so already a
very strong player here uh let's uh
let's see why this game is so incredible
and why everyone talks about it and why
this game and not so many others that he
played because he played incredible
games is considered to be Jon's Immortal
game so let's check it out Alexander has
the white pieces and he opens with Pawn
to D4 we have Knight to F6 uh Pawn to C4
uh G6 Knights the C3 and Bishop to G7
the king's Indian defense is on the
board and we have Ponta E4 they are
going for the standard stuff here we
have Ponte D6 and now Ponte F3 Alexander
goes for the balowsky for the semish
variation against the king's Indian we
have castles and now Bishop to E3 these
are all very standard moves um being
played even today uh like ponti five
most popular here you could go upon the
sea five nights to C6 uh John goes
Knight beat the D7 it's a merely a
preparation for for C5 you will want to
challenge White Center at some point so
here we have uh Queen to D2 uh you can
Castle Queen side you can also trade off
your dark Square Bishop so useful move
and pawn to C5 just going after White
Center Alexander advances with Ponte D5
you don't have to do this you could also
just defend with Knight GT2 or you could
even capture with the captures on C5 but
this was principled at the time uh
Knight the E5 you've vacated this Square
so now of course the Knight can occupy
it and now Pawn to H3 and here already
very interesting
um uh things occur because now you can
see that by playing F3 and H3 Alexander
created a a lot of dark Square
weaknesses around the white king and
it's absolutely masterful how John uses
this to his Advantage he plays Knight to
the H5 and of course you should do this
you go after
uh the the dark squares here we have
Bishop to F2 stopping Knight G3 and now
just Pawn to F5 now these are all
standard Kings Indian uh defense ideas
so nothing
um uh you know uh new being played here
it captures Rook campers and F5 and now
we have Pawn to G4 uh it seems like uh
Jon just blundered a piece here but not
really this is a whole uh working as um
as he planned a rook captures on F3 was
played and now you can't capture The
Rook if you capture The Rook then you
blunder your queen so that's not gonna
work but here we have G characters on H5
and now Queen to f8 uh it's a it's a
beautiful move just giving up a piece
and now preparing all sorts of nasty
ideas the uh the bishop can come to F5
this bishop can now come to H6 put
pressure on the White Queen and uh the
the white king doesn't have time to run
away so here we have Knights the E4 uh
and uh after Knight E4 just Bishop to H6
uh attacking the White Queen now you're
not going to be able to Castle and you
have two options is basically you can
move the queen to E2 which means you're
parting with your queen because if
Knight to D3 check now you have to give
up your queen there's nothing you can do
the the bishop is now attacked three
times so you will have to capture and
after Rook captures you will have uh
Play Bishop characters on D3 now Queen
to four and uh okay you have some
compensation you have a knight and The
Rook for the queen but still very
difficult to play let's say Rook to D1
you can play Bishop to F5 bring the Rook
into the game with Rook to f8 it's uh
it's hard hard to imagine that white
will be able to survive this so instead
Alexander plays Queen to C2 and now of
course uh just mounting up the attack
with Queen to F4 uh this is a slight
imprecision I will just mention because
this is uh well the game has been
analyzed so many times uh Rook therefore
is the move you want to play here uh
um John played Queen to F4 with pretty
much the same idea he wants to play
Bishop to F5 but he doesn't want to play
it right now while uh blocking his Queen
so instead of Rook the four he played
Queen to F4 but book therefore would
have given him the the best path to
victory for example Bishop G2 now you
play Bishop to F5 and after white on
pins now you go B5 and you open up the
position you put the Rook on B8 and this
is how you enter the game uh but okay he
played Queen to F4 instead and now uh
the question is how can Alexander defend
this is basically the one chance that he
gave him where he could have defended uh
but he has to capture The Rook it looks
like a silly thing not to capture the
rook and it's the only way for white to
defend uh but it's very hard to find the
problem is after Knight captures an F3
and Knight captures an F3 with check you
have to play King to D1 and not after
Bishop to F5 going after this Knight you
have to play Bishop to G3 this is the
move that saves the white and you have
to give back a little bit of material
let's say queen T3 Queen to D3 uh you
you're just gonna play Queen captures on
e4 and after black wins back the piece
Bishop G2 and white survives it's uh
it's it's now a game so nothing is
happening but this was the only way to
do it however he played Knight the E2 he
didn't calculate everything precisely uh
went for the queen and here he thought
okay now the Queen's gonna Retreat I'm
just gonna put a rook in G1 I'm gonna
play H Captain G6 I'm gonna uh attack
the black king because I'm the one that
wants to attack here but John said nope
uh Rook captures an F2 and now you can't
capture the queen if you capture the
queen then a rook captures the White
Queen on C2 so here Knight captures an
F2 was played and now Knight to F3 with
check and okay uh White is up material
but uh look at your king it's completely
boxed in King to D1 and now how do you
continue the attack every move matters
here it matters in most positions but
here it's really uh uh you know all
about that one tempo uh you want to get
your Bishop to F5 to attack the White
Queen and get the Rook to f8 but without
wasting time because your queen is also
hanging so here Queen to H4 moving the
queen with Tempo the only way to
continue the attack as the Knight is now
hanging and white basically the only
thing white got out of the position is
that he's up material so if he gives
them gives up material he's just gonna
have a worse position so Knights the D3
and now Bishop to F5 now the bishop
comes into the game and the Rook comes
into the game next now we have Knight
eat the C1 here you could even consider
a move like Knight E to F4 but it's uh
I mean who plays such a movie so it's
sort of a you know uh a crazy Engine
line that sort of allows white to maybe
defend after Queen to F2 but uh I mean
uh okay I just want to throw it to you
but it's a very unlikely that a human
will play that but okay Knight eat the
C1 was played and now we have knighted
the D2 beautiful move by John
uh by playing Knight to Z1 uh you could
consider some Queen to have two uh ideas
just trying to trade off the Queens
maybe uh get more pieces in front of the
the white king but now after Knight to
D2 the White Queen is again completely
out of the game and uh what pretty much
all of his pieces are out of the game he
played age captures on G6 for the lack
of a better move but now Jon plays a
move that is absolutely beautiful he
plays H captors and G6 he just
recaptures the pawn uh he could just
play Knight captures on C4 and it's game
over there's really no no good way to
meet this uh but he I guess he just
wanted to show him that his position is
so good that he can even uh abandon any
initiative and he can just recapture a
pawn he played age captures on G6 I I
think it's a remarkable uh idea uh and
now uh Bishop to G2 the problem is
there's no defending the C4 Pawn if you
play something like B3 then comes Queen
to E4 attacks the rook and now look at
this the the the dance of the queen and
the Rook Rook to G1 now Queen to E3
again is The Rook you can't go to H1
because Queen F3 check will pick up the
rook and if you play Rook the G2 again
Queen F3 check and now either your
Bishop hangs or you defend it with the
bishop and then the rookangs and like we
said if you give up the material then
you're just left with a terrible
position and you're still gonna get
checkmated it's not that your life
quality of life has improved in any way
so instead of this silly B3 move Bishop
the G2 was played and now just Knight
captures and C4 it I mean just just
waiting for for the inevitable we have
Queen to F2 uh offering a queen trade
but now just Knight the E3 with check
King to E2 and now Queen to C4 uh even
uh even doing this now just keeping the
tension and preparing Rook to f8 because
you're creating a masterpiece here and
you don't want the uh poor Rook on A8 to
be you know the turtle feel left out so
why not include him and okay we have
Bishop to F3 you know the Rook to f8 is
coming and now Rook the f8 we have Rook
the G1 playing something but there
really isn't anything to play Knight to
C2 now uh the Knight is now coming to D4
King to D1 sidestepping this even giving
uh giving up a rook on A1 here Alexander
is trying everything just to maybe
survives in some way uh but here John
just played Bishop captures on D3 and he
was in this position on a move 27 uh
that uh Alexander resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so a truly an incredible game and um the
problem is there's no move for white
white does not have a move for the for
the past 15 moves basically is uh let's
say Rook to G4 you attack the queen
there's Knight the E3 check and even if
you try trading Queens with Queen
captures on E3 uh first a nice check
will be given an after let's say this
now you wander the queen and that's it
if Rook to G2 can even be cheeky about
it and even give back the queen and
Checkmate white like this so pretty much
every line ends in in some sort of a
brutal Checkmate uh but yeah after uh
this uh uh this bishop to G2 move no
another for Bishop to G2 after Bishop
capture Sandy three 3 he resigned and
this is the game that is considered a
non's Immortal game and now you can see
why and it's uh also very instructive
that if you if you're a king's Indian
player and or you play a lot against the
king's Indian now if you put this
position to an engine the engine will
say okay uh if the engine will say black
is slightly better if you let the engine
crunch the numbers long enough uh the
engine will say it's 0.00 because every
position is either a draw winning or a
loss the problem is uh and it's
something that I really enjoyed the
Anish giri are talking about during the
World Chess Championship coverage uh he
said that we should have new engines or
maybe that the new engines are even
being considered now that okay this
position is 0.00 but if you check the
database if you check all the data the
games being played on on leeches and
chills.com on another websites uh there
should be okay it's a 0.00 but uh how
often does white win this and how often
does Black win this and if you put like
this position to such engine he will
tell you okay it's a zero zero but black
wins ninety percent of games white wins
like maybe five percent of games and
five percent end in a draw so having
that in mind we would consider uh not
playing this as white I mean even though
you can maybe play it uh if you know
that the white it's very hard to play
and you will probably lose then uh maybe
avoid such a line so also something to
consider and you know don't just listen
to the engine saying 0.00 I'm gonna play
this against the strong Grand Master no
he will he will obliterate you
uh so yeah uh that's uh that's basically
the the game that's John's uh Immortal
game uh hope you guys enjoyed it uh I I
thought about showing other games says
today is his 68th birthday but I thought
no this is the one that you guys
requested the most Let's uh let's
finally show it and now you've seen it
how how such a you know slight
positional uh inaccuracy like like
opponents the pawns on F3 and H3 uh can
result in in such a you know a game that
will be shown uh shown everywhere for
for like the next 200 years
uh so yeah and once again really hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Oscar Roto uh ABC's of just for kids
Alex Roseman Kim Tori Jensen and the
Jackal beat for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the World
Chess Championship at once it resumes
tomorrow uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day